okay hello everyone welcome to a wolf
and language design review this is the
beginning of our season of version 13.2
design reviews
and we are starting
this morning afternoon or whatever it is
for you uh with machine learning
so
uh where do we start
Julio well okay so uh first thing
we have uh began our update of classroom
functions so I've been working to hook
up automation at the support for fixed
number of clusters for more methods so
in general we are going to try more
things this is on average it's going to
give better results and we also have a
bunch of speed improvements under the
hood not nothing
let's be explicit what are we looking at
here
no no I'm just just going through the
notebook that you have in the other in
the other uh tell me what I'm supposed
to be looking at yeah here nothing
it says Automation and more methods what
are the more methods no sorry the the
the sentence is cut uh there we wanted
them support for for fixed number of
cluster for more methods it was
something that was completely missing we
had only a couple of uh of Master
support in that right so it's the most
used method
so I'm sorry I'm confused this is
partitions data into n clusters
that that was not supported for some of
these clustering methods
okay so so they could return fewer
clusters
if you specify that you want five
classes okay you really want to fight
yeah I got it I got it okay fine all
right any more to say about that
um no I mean it's it's actually a big
update but it's mostly on the hood right
now so it will surface a lot of uh extra
information for clustering uh uh that we
are exposing because it does it have
design consequences or is it just no no
no no this is not no you no nothing
visible here you know spanning tree for
example allows you to specify we want
eight clusters or something yeah exactly
now it works for example Spanish 3 is
exactly one of those that has been
updated to support fixed number of
clusters
so
let's see but here it says can only be
used when the number of clusters is
specified
so are there any way you can't specify
the number of clusters yes you can see
automatic so that's the reverse I'm
saying I'm saying even after this update
are there now ones where you could not
get it to work with specifying that you
want eight clusters or whatever
yes some of them they still don't work I
I'm the problem okay but I mean but is
they not is them not working just a
technical issue that's going to get
fixed or is it something where that
method just makes no sense to ask for a
fixed number of clusters it's some it's
uh is a letter some of them they were
implemented in the vanilla way and there
are ways to extend them and this is what
I'm I'm doing yeah but the ones where
they are unextendable probably there
should be a note that says that here
yes yes we we have yes we have a message
now which is a lot more completed I
understand that but you should have a
statement here just like this says can
only be used by the number of customers
specified there's other ones which
cannot be used with a fixed number of
clusters it makes sense yes right I like
it let's move on
clustering measurements
so I don't understand what this is this
new and yes this is new so up to this
point we had no way to measure uh to
compute any any measure on clusters we
actually we had internal code that was
doing that for for to guiding the for
example number of classes selection when
it was unspecified but uh
accepted we usually say possible
clustering specifications
I don't understand what this is this
doesn't even make sense this isn't
English except no no you're right
Stephen you're right okay yeah it should
be possible
yeah okay all right but so let me
understand what this is doing now
this is taking clusters
and giving out measures
that are like basically the equivalent
of accuracy precision for supervised
classification these are used for
unsupervised specification
and these are uh
how this corresponds to classifier
measurements for example by the way
whatever this is is not acceptable what
is that is that some kind of text
it should be a grid right this yes yes
sorry as I said
um I'm not as prepared as I wanted
because last week I was out the whole
week uh and I was sick but yeah this is
the summary is not it's not that final
form of the summary
okay but it's going to be a grid yes yes
yes or is it going to be a data set
maybe it should be data data sets
because then you can take things out
yeah this is just a table form uh it's
it's temporary the summary is a data set
actually in the implementation
okay fine data set is the right thing I
think yeah
um
well I have no opinion about these but
but I mean basically I don't quite
understand
so there is this is not complete Stephen
but you know
um these eponymous names
I mean for for properties and whatnot
um they say nothing except as a key to a
joke list right yeah I understand same
with the special functions they say
nothing yeah
um and so their attempts to explain them
now it's not quite finished yet but that
will go better so you should be able to
learn about them here
okay okay but but hold on let me just I
mean if I say fine clusters and then I
say I don't know
um
I'm sorry this is not the last version
of The Ref page I pushed one few hours
ago I don't know oh for goodness sake
well
sorry I just noticed
okay
all right so here's a fine clusters so
now you're telling me that this thing
that now I say clustering measurements
of that
yeah no no no I told you why I mean it
should have been in the world type it
there was a failure on team City uh it's
gonna be in in
I fixed it today it's gonna give you a
summary of all the measures about this
clustering
as a data set exactly exactly okay all
right okay fine all right let's move so
you will be able to the nvid is that you
will be able if you want to kind of uh
show off like what's what's going on the
like similar exactly that you have a
classifier you want to show a QRC F1
score big criteria
and and some of them are very useful to
understand and we extended some of them
they typically give you one number for
the whole clustering but we extended
some of them to to give you results per
cluster or or in case of silhouette
score per example so you can actually do
quite a bit of digging inside and and
figure out uh if for example I know you
identify customer groups and only one is
not very good in terms of grouping
things together this is
this is something where there's a
correspondence between the measurements
and the individual elements and there
are other ones where there's a
correspondence between the lists of
between between the Clusters and the
measurements
exactly exactly the literature the
literature indices they are typically
just a single number
throughout the whole process but we
wanted to to be to give a option to
particularly to dig deeper basically
look inside yeah I don't have a great
sense of how our star measurements
functions have been you know to me some
of the image measurements functions are
kind of a hacky way into all kinds of
detailed things that I want about images
I'm not thrilled with the fact that that
I'm basically just you know it's a it's
a jokes by numbers type adventure to
find them and I'm not sure
some of them we have sidestep the
problem completely for example by adding
support for statistics functions
directly on images Max mean min
those were like uh in image measurements
because there was no other place where
to put them
but stuff I like classify a measurement
for example we use a lot it's kind of
the end of every every piece of code
that uses classify you want to do the
measurements yeah
so for machine learning especially for
unsupervised learning you want to have
some guidance especially when you go
beyond the two 3D where you don't get a
visual sense anymore
but okay and then this will will be able
we will we will be able to expand on
this similar to how we expand the
classify measurement with stuff like
confusion Matrix plot so my my idea to
extend this is you know we can add like
uh um I was looking with Shady at the
the the community graph plot
where we can have some kind of uh nice
uh visualization for some of these
things
with respect to clusters you mean yes
with refers to clusters like dedicated
functionality for clusters fine all
right let's move on this is good fine
improve method selection for classify
what should I do
no there's nothing explicit here the
demote is working hard under the hood to
make the automation better and we
discussed last week that this will lead
to also better reporting
uh but yeah there's no nothing explicit
about that yet
now before the new version will just be
slightly faster better under that would
find better methods so okay highlight
string we've been talking about yep yeah
we've been talking about this recently I
implemented what you suggested in terms
of tight wrapping or before we move on a
little bit Yeah so one thing I think we
do need to do is to establish Benchmark
for what we mean by better method
selection this is this is a big part of
what Timothy is working on like he has
got the data sets and uh so he he
started by creating baselines using all
our example datas we have quite a
collection of example data sets and now
they form a kind of a standard Benchmark
every time we we tweak something
so uh we we are working hard not to be
blind anymore
all right good or to be less blind but I
wanted to you know when we do this thing
here I I I I I should have pushed that
but I was also sick all the next week
um last week as well we were all sick at
the same time it was pretty horrible
it's as if you know we should all be in
the same office then we'd have a reason
to be sick at the same time right it
makes me concerned that the viruses have
jumped to digital yes
I'm here yeah right so well I didn't get
covered but I haven't been this sick for
10 years so
um but but anyways I want to have this
when we do this reviews we say something
is better this and that that we show
you know we can show Benchmark wise what
got better and how much
uh you want to show that
here but also it's also for something
that you can then use if you write the
blog or rewrite the blog yeah yeah it's
like I just I'd like this stuff yeah I'm
saying things got better and then yes
mysterious right okay let's move on here
um
highlights too what are we really I mean
you you look at this last time you had
some suggestions
um I implemented most of them except for
uh the the multi-level visualization
because the uh yeah I wanted to work on
that last week and so the do you want to
type the tight highlighting if the
highlighting was ending in between words
so now that is implemented
so if I stay here
um okay this is whoops
um
okay that seems to have a lot of space
there well okay yeah let me see what
happens if I say text to this
is that right
I mean this is what taxi is doing on a
string yeah I'm not no no I understand
that I understand it but I think this
has too much space here
and if I say
yes we look at this last time and you
say it was fine as they said what I
understood it was fine if it was ending
in onward separators but if you end in
between now is is uh you see is doesn't
add Active Space because between on and
that's sensible yeah that's sensible
that looks good so you you still get the
nice highlighting with the pop-up if it
is a full word but it doesn't then do it
what do you mean by pop-up what do you
mean by pop-up the the the the kind of
highlights more
um then another thing you asked for was
uh to have blending colors uh because we
in my first version didn't support it
was not finished support for the nested
highlighting for intersecting
highlighting okay so let me do that here
so if I say 512 and then I say you know
10
14. in this case you have the same label
so they are just gonna go the same but
if you highlight them with why does that
why why is this on stay strong that the
is and the honest stay strong yeah
something goofed up sorry you goofed
oh no sorry they're just not merge so
this is this is a decision that that we
we have to take here exactly so if you
add the labels we see what's going on is
it
um so forget about the the list that is
the part that I had to finish up last
week but we we need to decide what you
think we're doing what will it look like
in the Fishbowl case
um the our idea was I mean the the the
design for the for implementation of
this was a text structure where they you
had multiple lines okay okay fine well
you have to see that I can't tell what's
going on without saying that
but now are you telling me that's a that
there's some kind of merged color here
yes I mean
these colors this is the expression
color which is generated by by The
annotation so they are quite close but
by chance if you change a bit one of the
two strings with something like
something else it will use a different
color
and you will see the you are suggesting
that this should blend so the the color
in between is a blend between the one on
the right and one on the left all right
I mean we're probably gonna have to do
another review of this because you're
obviously not finished with this
no no I mean there's one one uh last
threshold development for for this uh
the the that should be done and I had
there's some questions that I wanted to
ask is why I wanted to bring it up
because I took to to to Lou and itai
about the Box structure of this and uh
there's a decision of what do we want to
do uh when the label is like in the
imagine this gives a good example like
uh goes when the label is long okay this
we discussed last time this we need we
need string functions to support graph
themes instead of characters
that was what was the original the the
okay
what are we going to achieve in this
meeting what would you like to achieve
in this meeting so I I want I want to
ask you one one specific thing what I
was saying before like if the label is
very long and the highlighted string is
very short
do you want to push the text
because I asked in the front end has no
native structure that can represented
like an overflowing thing
or on on The annotation line
um you need an arrow not
minus
now if it is very very long but there's
somebody garbage here this is missing
garbage here you got to deal with this
case but something else is not labeled
that's got to work
oh yes I still see your point uh but my
question stands like what do you want to
do with a very long label when there's
no space to to display it
I think we should develop you know and
we're doing it this elsewhere a general
election scheme and so for instance you
know so it's dots in the middle it has a
tool tip when you hover over it
and things like that
seems reasonable to me but I'm not sure
that we want to always scuff it into the
space that's available do we
I mean this looks
as reasonable I mean
I think we're going to need a choice of
what to do here I think we you might
want either of those things I mean it's
I think you're right there could be a
wrapper around a label that says
optionally you know illusion it could be
an option to highlight string
the label well look there's different
choices you can line wrap it you can
align it you can just have it be full
like this one is here
I just noticed that we need it in a
bunch of other places it's a good
wrapper to have like for instance if you
have plot Legends and if you have a
paragraph long
um no look this is what short and so on
were developed for long ago
okay and we probably need a better you
know this is a we probably need a
version of short
that is better I mean that's basically
what it comes down to I mean I know yeah
yeah and I mean short is a very old
function that hasn't really been
modernized and probably does need to be
modernized and I I would recommend that
we not make a new function that is
basically doing the same thing that
short does
and um I mean unless
you know I think the problem is short is
it's a line based thing and we might
want
um
I mean what we want is something
where
it gives a reasonable illusion of a
thing to fit in a certain space
right just like which is essentially
what short is doing
yeah but one thing that we ran into for
instance in other contexts I'll just
bring it up here because these are like
use cases that you gradually come up
with when you evolve such a function so
for instance in some areas
like a system modeler the names for
variables and they have it's like our
context names yeah yeah okay and so
what's significant is the end not the
beginning I know I know for instance and
so where you Allied kind of matters
yeah you know yeah right well so but I
mean that's something hmm
I mean like a context name type thing we
should know about I mean this is very
very old this is kind of like version
one style technology here yeah I think
we need to have a discussion and it's
probably part of ild yeah maybe LCC
about short and basically generalizing
short because I think that short is um
it's a little bit short on functionality
I would say that yes you could say that
if you wanted to you know it says end
lines long right and we've always got to
generalize that to character counts or
or alternatively what I would suggest is
that that second element there but also
you know when you have an interactive
element that that second element should
be a a thing whose length determines the
length of short isn't that like pain or
a panel I don't remember which one with
line breaks
yeah that's what that does yes right no
no but there are other things like the
question is you know that thing it
shortens out can you drill into it
somehow I know I know we're supposed to
be able to we you know that was a
feature we were going to add in version
one and we didn't get around to it and
then 35 years went by and
so now we've got to do it
okay there's also the thing that this is
mostly tax based like uh it doesn't know
about image size
so let's so let's clean it up
Arlo was asking about rotated labels I
mean you can use a rotate wrapper on the
label and it will display rotated
it supports any expression there
yeah okay fine good but I'm telling you
let's get a a meeting to discuss short
and its generalizations and religion and
so on because we've known for a long
time we need that this is a case where
we need it and and you're going to do
this okay let's keep going with this
meeting
yes okay
here here we have right now we have a
network that performs the same in terms
of accuracy but okay one third larger is
totally unacceptable is the ridiculous
startup time of image identifier which
must be fixed
okay this just it's just a waste of time
right now it was it was fine a few years
ago it was it was doing just fine and
then it okay you reported to me that you
had the two minutes start a time without
any download no good and no good but
that I I couldn't produce on any other
machine
we're doing it right now okay you can
measure the time I get out my stopwatch
by the time okay
no it was not fast no it was not this is
a built-in system function built-in
system functions have to return quickly
they can't just get to go blah blah blah
blah for ages
and it didn't show any okay so that's
that's fine what they did there is fine
but the initial
thing it's got to show a progress
monitor if it's taking you know it was
15 seconds or whatever it was I mean I
can I can redo it here let's redo it
can you can you run something else just
make sure that the kernel is up because
we have current startup time
okay
okay
you can do
absolute timing
I don't believe absolute timing I'm
going to use my stopwatch okay
this is [ __ ]
just [ __ ]
okay I got about seven seconds on my
stopwatch this is this is no good just
no good right that's just no good
if you put up a progress dialogue and
we've got a solution for the cloud then
it's okay but six seconds is no good for
a system function
but some some progress thing uh will
have to be more General like uh right
now loading packages uh doesn't doesn't
have any progress information and like
exactly I'm telling you so this is no
good right so better would be not to
have the six second delay
am I making sense
yes this is
what to say about it okay then put on a
progress dialogue okay I'll I'll I have
to talk to Todd and see if we can have
some progress uh information for for
buglets well we need it sorry this isn't
going to work and Avery can you make
sure that this is tracked please because
this is not something that can ship you
know I'm pretty upset that image
identify got so unbelievably much slower
is I assume that what I'm running here
is the new version of image identifier
is that correct
you've got a thing to fix here let's
make sure yes okay what's next
uh you can look at an external object I
think this wrapped up very nicely as a
project
to not be loading yeah
um
this is of course the first iteration
where we run on on next models and uh
this is uh we we are putting together
examples and they they are agrees to to
run to totally use now
so this is this is used to basically
rubber Supply what type of model it is
where is that specified in the united
external object no no right now no
because you see this is future not right
we started the the road map is we start
with one and X we actually have already
MX this is not adequate documentation I
mean
okay
I don't understand this this is you're
saying you say file of something which
is a DOT on an x file right
no you see this is this is all future
right in 13.2 this is going to be
returned by import you can import things
as net external object without doing any
conversion we already had
one next import but it was trying to
convert stuff to our framework and it
wasn't working in all cases now it's
gonna buy by definition work in every
case because we are we are using the
Onyx runtime to run the model as a black
box
this means that it is actually extremely
convenient to test any model that you
find in the wild okay but I understand
that but the inputs to that model how do
you know that they are converted to the
right data types and all that kind of
thing
right those are how we have to be
numbered it is the naked outside thing
so I I talked to Mateo and my idea for
this is to support net encoders and net
decoders similar to our Networks
this is something that we are uh I don't
understand at all you've got some random
Onyx Network and it expects an image and
a list of dates and some other random
and uh no no on its network with only
like any any external network will only
expect pencil data okay fine by
definition
okay so this is a pure tensor story and
then it gets wrapped by things which are
net encoders net decoders
if you scroll down you you see an
example of like a real case via use case
so okay this is a very efficient
detector
so right now we import it as an external
object
we use a net encoder and a net decoder
so uh I I want to extend that as an
object to be able to support encoders
and decoders but this this will come in
the next situation so uh right now you
can just use encoders and decoders as
functions and basically this is
little code to run a random uh a random
model in an external frame
but let me just understand this
I see so that's what it looks like it
literally is running
the classifier is the net external
object
exactly yeah that's pretty nice it's
pretty nice
and arguably
and if if we manage to bundle like I'm
finally my Mateo's time was spent like
like a month or more to to fix uh
um stupid them Etc um regression that
were hampering the framework but we
could we could do I think we did a very
good foundation here and in the next
version we want to embed the encoder and
decoder in the net extender object so
you will not even have to specify them
separately in the in the function call
yeah I understand and it's quite fast so
if you scroll down I have an example of
object detection sorry
so when you specify the encoder and
decoder there will be some Association
inside the net external object
presumably that says that basically says
in there
it'll have an encoder element of the
association the raw classifier the
decoder Etc does that make sense
we can specify them the same way as we
specify them for networks and in the
concept of ports is the same in every
framework like in into the port images
you can attach an image tell me
specifically what you're talking about
here
okay like look again at the classifier
example so the first the first
um
the first Port is that image if you
click on plus it sees like it also tells
you which are input ports and which are
output ports in the in the summary box
for example
okay so this one here is our toy model
in example data but the the the one
below okay is uh so let's see that you
know this one takes images uh but it's
just a name images let's say that you
really want to apply this on images
so I want to use the same syntax that
the port image is zero
no we'll be dressed with the net encoder
image
okay
this will work the same as our framework
so we will then you could we you will be
able to use this but this is
by the same as the framework you mean if
I say I mean in net model do we have
such a mechanism no yes of course yeah
if you if you if you do net model or
from image95 that takes an image and
returns an entity
is that
how is the dressing specified
well the net model is when when you in
this case is already built in yeah
[Music]
when you have to specify it how is it
specified here
um
I'm asking where do you put maybe the
net encoder where do you he's already
put in net model is right okay
when you have to put it in explicitly
where do you put it in in that draft in
a chain okay fine
but so then you're suggesting that net
external
model
net external object rather has in it
I see this is what you're saying like a
like a port this one has no encoders
because it's just from the connectivity
but uh
okay I understand
cool all right great what's next here so
uh in terms of new functions to look at
um
right what else are we trying to achieve
in this meeting
or can we consider that we're wrapped up
well the most of the world what we have
been doing this summer was uh kind of
under the hood preparation that's great
so I think these these things are the
first visible uh but it's going to be
okay so I mean this meeting was set up
as a design review and was it missed
setup I make sure it had been set up in
three weeks or something or what was the
what's the point here because it didn't
seem like it was a lot to review here
we have new new pages and new symbols
and uh
to see what they are and uh except for
for highlight string all the others are
are in a pretty ready state so if you
are not happy is now or or uh no no I am
happy so I mean I think we're all good
is there anything else I should look at
here no no that this is it
it's nice I mean it's good stuff it's
it's all listen the fact that stuff is
under the hood and doesn't require you
know design grinding is you know that's
good news it's not you know that's
that's nice
um and one thing I want to mention uh is
that in the end the net external objects
turn out to be pretty fast so I put an
application example in the ref page
where you can import an object detection
Network and uh that can you know you can
do when detection in real time and I
think that this opens up many
interesting opportunity for deployment
in terms of
just one one side thing that uh given
that they worked hard I wanted to to
kind of mention that is the application
example if you scroll down to the
to the end of the page
um
you see this one here so this is a again
removing the the lines of text is is a
very vertical size a way to import a
model that you know nothing about and
and run it
which one here what which one are you
looking at
the the this is an object detection yeah
so the the we start by defining the
image and the detector which is this uh
net external object that you see output
for
uh
and then we just wrap the the resulting
rectangle basically and use highlight
image and then we have a face detector
this is a very actually it's a nice
model it's like one megabyte model
you could run on the phone
yeah well maybe we should be using that
I mean you know this business about
speeding up our
you know machine learning and neural net
models it's really important
you know this is a five second delay
it's just no good
the goal for Visa is not just picking up
the models he's also speeding up the uh
you know like let's say the image team
wants to test new models I can do it
very fast now I'm well aware of what the
objective of this is okay okay great
right it's great okay
um
okay all right but yeah I I look into
Mission if I and and uh and redo the I
mean the first time it was speeded up uh
we look at all the partials and and then
brought them down we are going to do
that again
um okay
sounds good all right anything else
oh thank you very much thanks thanks
okay